Israeli strikes continue targeting the
south of the strip at least 29
Palestinians have been killed in two
separate attacks on residential
buildings women and children make up the
majority of those killed including a
baby several people have been injured
and have been taken to the Kuwaiti
Hospital in Rafa the Israeli hos Israeli
Army rather has been pounding Southern
Gaza in recent weeks after it forced
Palestinians to move from the north
saying it was for their safety more than
19,000 Palestinians have been killed in
Israel's war on
nearly 85% of the population have fled
their
homes well Han Mahmud is in Rafa in
southern Gaza honey can you bring us up
to speed on the very latest on these
strikes that have been taking place
overnight yes there are more people are
being killed overnight here in the
southern part of the Gaza Strip as more
Relentless air strike pounding more
residential homes in central RAF city as
well as the western side the very very
specific area that was designated as
safe area for more display and evacu
from across the Gaza Strip it's
important to point out that the vast
majority of people who have been killed
happen to be displaced and evacuates in
addition to those who hosted them inside
their residential homes the initially
the number was nine as of of last night
but early hours of this morning as more
people were removed from under the
rebels we're looking at uh a 29 people
have been killed the vast majority of
them have been me to be women and it
children we're looking at also a very
very young baby as well among those who
have been killed uh plus a journalist uh
who was uh who killed in the residential
home at the western side of rafan this
is not the first time this area has been
targeted it was targeted repeatedly over
the past weeks in addition to other
areas across Rafa City where we have a
more people are evacuating to we're
looking at in addition to the
260,000 local residents of Rafa the
number has increased to
1,300,000 as more people keep pouring uh
into Rafa City looking for shelters uh
among those displ and evacu in Raa City
and honey we' be getting some more
pictures some new pictures from the
jabalia refugee camp to the north uh
what can you tell us about what's been
happening there
MH yes within the past half an hour two
residential homes in jabalia refugee
camp been targeted and Destroy at
statement by the director of of Health
in the in Gaza and the northern part
talked about 10 people have been killed
already and more than 25 been critically
uh injured and again this is also not
the time the first time that the jabal
refugee can been targeted we've seen the
past weeks of of the war where entire
residential blocks being destroyed and
turned into pile of rebels this is part
of the continuous uh genocidal war and
War of extermination of Palestinians
particularly when we look at the victims
of those Relentless attacks happened to
be children and women there is an entire
generation of children more than 7,000
children have been killed since the
beginning of the war that's an entire
generation of of children that will
likely to impact uh the growth of the
the Palestinian Society in the future to
a negative level H hanim Mahmud in Rafa
in southern Gaza thank you very much